>> VEJMELKA GOT A WIN AGAINST
THE CHICAGO WE ROLL ON,USH, THE
COYOTES GET CAUGHT WITH A
DEFEFE
FORMERLY WITH THE SAVE BY
VEJMELKA, VERYPPORTUNITY,SON CRS
TIME.
NOW BACKHANDED BY
FISCHER.
GOSTISBEHERE WITH T HERE AT
GILA RIVER ARENA.
ACTIONACROSS, THE COYOTES GET ID
AND I THINK THE QUICK BRINGS IT.
IN BEHIND BACKCHECK
BY THE PREDATORS, AND JOSI.
GOSTISBEHERE'S ON IT, GOES UP
THE BOARDS, HE SPOTS FROM
THERE. IT'S
CLEARED OUT.
>> I DON'T MIND MA PLAY AT GETTS
IN THE SECOND, OUTSHOOTING
NASHVILLE 6-1 SOOSIER ONCE AGAIS
INVOLVED.
THAT PUCK JUST BEST.
TAMPA, THEY HAVE LOOK
>> JOSI ON T.
YOU GET ONE, YOU'RE RIGHT BACK
INTO THE THAT WORKS!
THAT'S WHAT G HIGH, DUCHENE, SWT
AWAY.
GRANLUND HATE.
IN BEHIND THEHOLM, ACROSS.
ONE-TIMER BLOCKED AWAY.
COYOTES WILL PICK THINGS HAPPEN.
AND HE ALMOST BURIES ANOTHER
ONE.E. RIGHT
POINT.
BRINGS IT RIGHT BACK INS ON THE.
HITS THE BACK OF THE VEJMELKA. .
SHOT TO THE FRONT, RIGHT ON JUST
>> PLAYE